so
hi my name is uh thomas de caminovec
i am here in costa rica and i
am a visiting professor at the leed
university
and as of recently as i will explain
um started working
actually for the pan-american
health organization and
well i had very different plans for
for this talk i was going to give
actually a lot of data analysis
on on the covet situation in costa rica
but since i started last week in the
pan-american health organization i am
not authorized to do that because i'm
now
uh represent the pan american health
organization and any
opinion or something i i say
affects the diplomatic relation in terms
of health of the organization and
different countries since
the pan-american health organization
gives advice to costa rica the
government of costa rica
i'm involved now in that team that
prepares and analyzes but the good thing
is that
before i was kind of an outcast or sort
of uh
doing my own analysis uh as part of uh
just as an independent citizen but now
i can do the same thing but then i think
hopefully
it will help to to to get the government
to understand
and to to be able to to have um good
strategies to control the disease
so basically well i'll be talking about
covet
and it's a very trendy subject
um it in cobit is is it's a bit of a
well it's a very particular
disease and and that's why it hit us
rather abruptly and surprisingly one of
the
some of the things that are very very
makes them very different from
other diseases is this being
asymptomatic
and but in particular being
pre-symptomatic meaning that
you can be infective you can be
infecting people but
show no symptoms in in that time
you think you're okay but you're
actually infecting people the other
thing is
that it is it actually travels in
aerosol
and and then because of that it's
also airborne and that's actually
recently was
actually confirmed as such that it is
actually an airborne
a virus so that makes it really really
complicated so and then it's a
unknown disease it's an emergent disease
we don't have a vaccine
so everything kind of add up to
something that it's a
really large scale and human scale
problem
i think beyond that what we have seen
from from other
viruses in the past and the other thing
is
that we need to control human population
which is
very complicated like in other diseases
say for example
a h1n1 or something like that when
people get sick
they sort of auto
isolate themselves because they don't
feel well so they feel like i'm gonna
stay home because i don't feel well
but since covet you have this
pre-symptomatic
period that doesn't happen so then
it's actually you do have to control
human population not just
identify uh where where sick individuals
are but actually control
how humans behave and societies behave
in order to try to contain or mitigate
the effects of them
of the disease so that brings science
modeling
in politics in the same basket and it's
really difficult because
people have this notion that science is
it's exact and perfect and
and and you say things and they're
absolutely true
and they don't understand that that
science is
is the it's more the way it works and
being able to test ideas and being able
to propose ideas that have some
evidence or they're grounded in
evidence and then on the other hand
there's politics involved right when you
when you
put a some sort of strategy to control
at a human scale
then it's not that simple just to order
people to do something that they have
not done before
so anyway so
so well basically one of the the main
features of
of this this infectious disease that
that
it occurs by contact meaning that
the closer i am to a person uh the
higher the contact with that person and
the higher the probability that i will
get
infected so there is if you have an
infected person
and you're close to this person and
you're okay then
you have a chance a high probability of
getting
the disease yourself so then it moves
rapidly
by contact between people so imagine if
if you go to a
movie theater and there's one sick
person
and then the movie theater gathers
people from that
they don't necessarily know each other
but come from maybe
from uh close by
places but they don't really know each
other then and you have one sick
person then they all actually also share
the air conditioning
it's an enclosed space and so on so then
quickly
you get everyone everything everyone is
enjoying the movie but then when they
get home
they turn out they have a high chance
that they have hadn't
that they could have gotten the disease
and become infected
and so and you can see you have seen all
this right i'm not going to repeat
things that
people have already seen like this is
getting data from from
from this a kovit
resource data that that wolfram has is
very useful
and this is a just the data from india
and you can see
how quickly things uh start
spreading right you have confirmed cases
and and well this is this is just
amazing right you have a say in a few
months
here nothing much happened but then
suddenly
in a few months we're talking about in
the millions
so so then that kind of exponential
growth and then it turns out
and kind of flattens out a little bit
this is confirmed cases
so so this may then uh
turn out no more or should flatten at
some point
where you have no more confirmed cases
or the growth
decreases but then at this part is
it's really difficult to to control
because it moves extremely
fast and well you have seen all these
all countries has pretty much the same
type of
of uh dynamics so what do we need to
understand all this or
or how how we control this thing well
one of the things
is to understand precisely dynamics and
one of the things that they have seen
in in this situation is that actually
a lot of medical doctors are involved in
the
decision making and i have not seen so
many people in quantitative
sciences uh to be involved in in
in analysis in in working on production
so
so we do have to understand the dynamics
the underlying dynamics to be able to to
to make better predictions for sure then
we not only need to know the present
situation but then
we have to look at the past and see what
what effect some of the measures may
have happened or whether
what exactly when there was a uh some
sort of
an out an outbreak somewhere
then what particular situation happened
that that um
that allowed that outbreak to happen and
then of course to look at the future
right
because anticipation is is the main key
in this thing how to anticipate
something that's going to happen so
so i can plan the the health system to
take
uh whatever as many people that need to
take and then to
to avoid further spreading of the
disease and well how do we do that well
basically mathematical statistical and
computational models
just just to as a matter of fact as a
mathematical biologist i am a
mathematical
biologist in costa rica i didn't have
much you know i wasn't you know they
were not
not too many jobs as such for me as a
math biologist i mean
apart from academia but then suddenly
i became like a hot right because
when i started doing my own analysis of
the situation
then all these newspapers and in
media outlets started contacting me
because they wanted some
somebody that could understand the
quantitative part of the of the
epidemics
to be able to have some more insight and
then to to to
have to interview me for some more
information and disease so suddenly i
became somebody
that was really interested interesting
and and then he i started receiving
calls from everywhere and and for the
same reason now i started working
i started working at the paramedic and
health organization
and what we need is precisely the
scripted predictive
descriptive of course that's the most
common one just to see those
those famous cumulative and active cases
and
number of deaths and so on but that just
just tells us what's going on at this
point
we need also predictive tools or models
that can project
uh what's going to happen in a short or
long
or midterm or long term also
prescriptive
which means that something that i can
test
some strategy and figure out what would
be or
optimize it and figure out what we would
be the best way
of applying that strategy and also
retrospective to see
what we did if it worked if it's worth
doing again or we should just move on
and do some other things
so basically everything kind of starts
with sim models that are
very old and i did my own model my own
version of an sio model which i'm going
to present
and sar models i don't know probably
many of you know about
sir models because of this is a wolfram
conference so people know a lot of math
and statistics and computer science
so but it's but still i mean it's a very
actually
basic or simple straightforward way of
modeling the dynamics it just assumes
that you have a mixture of people that
are
susceptible and infected in a in a
population in this population it's sort
of like a container so you can imagine
that these are just gas particles
it just bouncing around inside a
container
and some of them have are infected and
some of them can become infected
and then you separate those
people that have as different categories
and you put them in different like
compartments
so you have a people that are
susceptible you have people that are
infected
and then infected and then they they can
become
recovered or die or something like that
so that's what the name comes from
susceptible infected and recovered
or removed and this is that's why these
are called sir model
and basically there is some some
way of modeling how infective
people infect susceptible and it's
called
the mass action law basically it's like
imagine
people just bouncing randomly against
each other in a mixture
and then there is then a contact rate
which we call mechanical beta and then
there is a probability of transmission
that we can call
alpha and that's how then people move
from this compartment
to the infected compartment so basically
people bounce with each other
infected infected people with
susceptible and then they move from
susceptible to
infected once they become infected there
is a rate at which
they become recovered or removed
depending on how you interpret
this ir a model
oops sorry ah do it
okay so in differential equations this
is this is a
system of of differential equations that
looks like this
it's actually very straightforward it's
basically what you subtract
on this on this on this uh this side
then on this compartment then it moves
so it subtracts here and then it moves
to the
infected compartment and then what it's
removed from here
moves to the recover compartment and
these describe the rates of change
of each each one of the compartments so
basically you try to
solve this or analyze this to understand
a bit of the the dynamics and the
disease and that's
these models i mean these models have
been
really used in in different contexts
like i don't i don't think that they
have been used
the way they've been used now in the
sense that the they have been used to
study
um some epidemia
or epidemio epidemiological phenomena
that
when it's already over right not when
it's occurring
at the same time so that's that becomes
a little bit difficult because then then
you
you if i mean you get the data on a
daily basis but you don't have the full
picture and you have to then
use them to do some forecasting or
prediction which are
which is different from from what what
i think what i have been doing before so
so then they became really popular
actually now the general population kind
of know when sir
model is the the good thing is that
these models do some of the ideas for
control come from these models
like for example reducing contact rate
which is it's now called social
distancing basically what you're trying
to do is reduce contact rate
and when you use mask and sanitizing and
wash your hands and that kind of thing
basically you're reducing your
probabilities infection
and then there is a quarantines right
where you actually
remove physically people that are
infective or
or or show symptoms and remove them from
the general
population or even like some sort of
it would be more like lockdowns where
actually you don't even allow people to
you almost to take the contact rate to
almost zero
which you actually almost physically
remove them from the
susceptible population and leave them in
a in in their homes without any
contact whatsoever and from these models
that you know the the
famous are not have become popular and
basically you can see it's
kind of really straightforward in the
sense that if you reduced
any of these parameters which is contact
rate and probability of of uh
transmission
then of course are not it's going to go
down and or if you increase
the removal rate which you can think of
more like quarantine
then also the this would go down in the
by the same token i mean if
if this is a a removed rate that that
has to do with death
then if this is very high meaning that
it's a
really deadly disease then or not
it's not going to be high because it
just it doesn't have enough time
to infect enough people and covet is
actually not
that lethal in that sense but it is
because it infects so fast people
then then because of large numbers you
have so many people that can
die and i have done work and are not and
this is a paper
i've written a long time ago to it's
actually a very nice method to calculate
or not for very complicated
uh systems of differential equations for
epidemiological
models so this is basically an sir model
and amazingly i have shown this in the
media
and basically this is the same system of
equations you have there and here i'm
just doing a numerical
solution and this this is the type of
shape you see
you initially infected here are red
initially you have
you have some some a population that is
susceptible
and then as they become quickly infected
it kind of
increases what it looks like to be
exponential
and then at some point there is an
inflection point and and kind of slows
that
slows down a little bit infection but
it's because there are no more
susceptibles available
until everyone is is infected and this
in this particular
this is a sort of a toy example and as
as soon as you remove
or people are being removed from the
population then you get this type of
shapes
that then here i'm making it really high
contact rate
this is a type of shape we're seeing
right where we see
really fast uh exponential growth
and then almost in a very short period
it kind of
it kind of levels levels out
and then it kind of slowly recovers
and this is the type of curve we have
seen with some some variations in that
it's a hump and then there's another one
increasing in the sense that are so uh
there are
several waves that are occurring and
it's because of the
with the way the covet um transmits
ah just a second so i
built a different a different model a
model that
that could include confinement so
basically i did an
seir model which includes the exposed
compartment because in in covet you have
a period
this period where you were you're
exposed to the disease
and you're actually infectious and then
you become infected you know
and it's because the way uh
we're dealing with the disease when you
become infected it's almost immediately
your quarantine because you're detected
as infected
meaning that you're removed from the
population so basically it's the exposed
basically
the ones that are actually um
transmitting the the disease in the
general population i i include
um in this model my the strategy is to
to use confinement as a way of
reducing the actual susceptible
population instead of just uh
just reducing contact rate and reducing
probability of
of infection i actually try to remove
part of the susceptible
population in order to to so they're not
available
to put it in to put it that way for
for being infected and then allows for
cyclic
cyclic lockdowns and um relaxation
events as i'll show you and then you can
include some other social
uh distancing hygiene and confinement so
that you can add these three things
basically social distancing energy
changes the
the contact rate and probability of
transmission and confinement
which is the rate at which you can put
people in lockdown
then also will have an effect on them on
the
on the program and the disease this is
sort of the
the this the schematics or the the how
it works you have a basic
basic sir models and i'm going to
concentrate on the b part
and then then you have a rate at which
a people are confined which are called
delta
and this is sort of a switch function
that i'll talk talk about
in a minute in the sense that the
government's turn on and off
this sort of confinement or which are
basically lockdowns right the site and
some levels of
of lockdown in some implementation of
some sort of a
human scale or city level uh lockdowns
or
or or something like that in terms of
equations uh
this is the system of referential
equations basically an seir
but then you can see there is this
confinement compartment
and there is this a in exchange
between being susceptible and confined
and you can move
about these two these two compartments
and at
you move to confinement at a delta rate
and you move back
to un to susceptible at a at a
a rate
this is the model in the in in
mathematica
it's basically the same thing uh
basically this is this is just with no
no um basically some some confinement
some way of reducing the available
susceptible population putting them in
confinement with some some measures
but no unconfinement and you get this
this type of um of a epidemiological
curve this is a number of infective
people and this is just a some sort of
numerical simulation just to
for display purposes but basically you
get
you look at this the shape it's a little
bit different perhaps
but then um you don't you don't get to
the entire population but only
here i'm settling the population of five
million people but
even though you have five million people
then
not everyone is really
susceptible because of this confinement
a strategy
that that doesn't allow everyone to be
susceptible and to be
infected
and the idea basic idea to do this model
was that
there's somebody normal named tomas
puedo kind of
published this and although he i would
say he popularized the idea he didn't
actually
came up with it because this is kind of
a strategy known in
in in epidemiology and then he came with
this idea of hammer and dance
sorry it's it's dance and basically
that you have a hammer period where you
have strong confinements and or
lockdowns
and then you have a dance period where
you relax so much the
social distancing measures and here's
some of the things you
do he or this person recommends that you
would do but then when your hammer
you're actually
doing really strong lockdowns and when
you dance
you're allowing some of the some of the
normal
activity to go back to normal and just
avoiding
some of the ones that are really risky
like like large gatherings and
and things like that so the idea was to
use this model to try this out
and basically then you can with this
psi function you can create something
like this where
where you do hammer and dance basically
where there is no
when when this is one there is a dance
meaning that people can move back to
susceptible
then when this is zero uh people only
move to confinement
and not to the susceptible population so
this is showing in a period of
so many days 200 days then you can you
can just have a
uh sort of a dance period and then back
to lockdown and then back to dance and
back to
to a long lockdown and you can change
that right that you can change the
how long these these lockdown periods
are
and then when when are they supposed to
start
and so on and so forth uh the idea of
this is to try to
assess how long these these lockdowns
should be so this applied to the to this
s e
i c r model uh including this switch you
would have something like this like this
is a
sort of a normal kind of really strong
lockdown situation
then you include some i'm gonna i'm
gonna move this and you include some
dance days
right here it's too short uh and then
you include some there you go
you include some some dance days that's
that's a bit too much
i'm gonna just add a little bit
and as you can see when you when you
have um
some periods of relaxations of the
measures then you would uh
presumably if you have not yet
got rid of of covet which would be very
hard then you would get
quickly uh periods of
of a big hump again a new wave
and as soon as you put measures back
then things um slowly will will start go
back to
to to again to to a control situation so
the idea of this model is basically
so you can include these switches that
allow um the start and the end
of uh of a lockdown period in this
there's some sort of delay
in which uh here's it's completely over
the the the lockdown the the relaxation
period and here just starts it takes a
while
for both to kind of take effect because
people stop moving
then from one compartment to the other
one and as they
it takes a while for them to to get back
in in it's it's indeed something like
that
in the sense that when you apply some
some lockdown measures at least in costa
rica
it it doesn't it's not instantaneous um
results right so then there's some sort
of delay
on that um the problem with this in
in sort of going almost done here
the problem with this is we have seen
the disease only
it's a very complicated control system
and it's a control system at a human
scale right where you have
you have a control system it's actually
the government and society
and then to system to be controlled it's
actually human populations and not only
human population but societies right
and it's not that straightforward and
you apply
some actions that have to do with social
distancing
communication some legal aspects
cultural aspects socioeconomical aspects
and so on and not only that when once
you have
in your system you have people the real
number of people infected and then you
have something you're observing
which might be different and it has a
lot to do with the
testing strategy so then you're actually
behaving in terms of something you're
observing
so that has to be understand understood
and analyzed using statistical
mathematical and computational modeling
and on top of that
you have to have some decision models
it's not just oh
if are not or are effective is this
value then
then do this it's not that that that
simple
and and then you have a desired
situation that
not only involves health biosecurity
um economy society education mobility
a lot of aerials so it's not as
so so straightforward
see
so there is one other thing that i've
been observing and
and i'm just this is kind of a naive way
of presenting it
i'm sort of thinking of an sir but now
you have somebody that's observing
that doesn't influence the system just
observing just imagine doing testing
just doing testing to figure out who's
sick and who's who has the infection
and some of the problems we may have is
that it's something like this
right in this particular situation you
have this is the actual number of
infected this is
actually a epidemiological curve but you
have a limited
way of of testing so then say you have
high positivity in testing and then
and you you what the dynamics you
actually
see it's very different from what
actually is going on
and there is you can kind of see that
some hump may happen but then
look at look how how deceiving this
could be right you see here
things are increasing but it's just a
way because the rate at which you're
doing testing
testing and then you have some sort of
uh saturated
way of doing testing so that has to be
taken into consideration
it's not just that we're looking at the
numbers of number of new cases where
that's a measure
of the population and then it's not
necessarily a representative
um a sample of the population so we have
to think of that
a little bit a little bit further and
not just um
just uh think just look at those numbers
and think
that we're actually seeing what is
really going on so we have to be really
careful
and on top of that we have asymptomatic
people that
can infect people that have i think a
lower rate of infection but can you
could infect
people so i i think that's it i don't
know if there is a
there is a there is a one question is
that you can't can you model your super
starting event yes indeed you could like
and that was mine of the idea is that to
do this this preliminary
uh model to do that kind of um
that kind of thing and test some of
those sort of um
heuristics on top of in in terms of what
kind of strategy
it could be best to try to control the
disease
in the file section i left then this
notebook and some papers in a preprint
of that model if anyone is interested
and thank you very much i think i run
went over one minute